we can tap into these altered states to
fundamentally
make better decisions to draw upon ideas
the diversity of thinking and the depth
of thinking just one level past what
you're used to
is the way to keep the whole garden
flourishing if you're not being defined
by a vision of the future then you're
left with the old memories of the past
and you will be predictable in your life
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to hack
your brain for greater success in
performance
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with hack number
one engage the mind with dr rahul john
dial
anything difficult where you have to
think
is good for your brain if you ask usain
bolt how do i get stronger legs to run
it's intuitive but the flesh in our
skulls
it's meant to think and feel and that
is the power of self-growth and it's a
thinking machine it's a thinking flesh
that you actually have to use or to
protect itself because it's an energy
hog right it's three pounds but uses
twenty percent
if you're not using parts of it it'll
program itself
to let those parts of the garden wither
so the diversity of thinking
and the depth of thinking just one level
past what you're used to
is the way to keep the whole garden
flourishing and it is a garden in there
there's chemicals
there are things moving there are
different types of brain cells it's not
just neurons
so i would try to give that metaphor
analogy if you will that
it's a garden and you have to irrigate
it and stimulate and tend to
all the corners particularly the ones
you're starting to neglect maybe it's
your left hand
getting out of the box and engaging the
recesses of your mind is the most
important thing and then you have the
then then the creative things happen you
don't just sit down and have them happen
you got to work
and dream and go hard and on top of that
something creative can happen
hack number two create behavior change
with mal robbins
so just a few years ago scientists
thought that our brains stopped growing
at the age
of about 25. what we now know is that
your brain
never stops growing we have the ability
to learn new things throughout
entire lifetime we call this behavioral
flexibility
one of the things that's exciting about
the five-second rule and that we see
from people all over the world is that
when they utilize the rule
over and over and over again they not
only create
immediate change in the moment with a
five-second decision
but that over time as they repeat the
new behavior whether it's speaking up in
meetings more
or it is pushing yourself to exercise
over and over
that you actually create new habits and
become
an entirely different person this is
what your brain
is designed to do in terms of its neural
pathways and the way that new neural
pathways can develop
every time you use the 5 second rule and
54321
activate your prefrontal cortex and
shift your behavior
you are not only creating immediate
behavior change
over the long run thanks to behavioral
flexibility
you're creating lasting behavior change
hack number three
tap into theta with vishen la kyani
probably eighty percent of the good
ideas that i have in the business come
from
think dating that's incredible right
eighty percent of your ideas are coming
when you're accessing these states now
that's what i'm talking about you're
accessing
an altered state of consciousness now
scientists can measure that if we hooked
up
tom's brain to an eeg machine what they
would see is that you're probably going
into you're probably going to see an
increase in alpha waves
and an increase in theta waves what
science is finding is that
alpha waves which is what emerges from
your brain when you are relaxed right
is is very soothing it's very relaxing
and if you continue relaxing more
you get into what is sometimes called
waking theta
data is the state your brain is in every
night
just before you fall asleep when you
fall asleep you go into a deeper state
called delta but here's the unique thing
when you're at data ideas flow in fact
there's this
legendary story of thomas edison where
and maybe you've heard this he would
he would practice this napping technique
where he would hold a metal ball in his
hand
and there'll be a metal tray below his
desk and he'd sit in his chair like this
and drift off to sleep and just as he
goes into sleep his hand would drop the
ball would clang on the tray
waking him up and he'd have his ideas
now what was he doing
he was dipping into data to pull out
ideas in fact
there's this this quote by edison which
says this
ideas come from space it's hard to
believe but it's true
ideas come from out of space now
isn't that similar to what you're doing
you're you're using your own language
but you're dipping into theta to pull
out ideas and you just said it 80
of your business ideas are coming from
the state that
that is what i want more people to
understand we can tap
into these altered states to
fundamentally make better decisions
to draw upon ideas and to even
increase our rate of getting towards our
ideas
so this is one of the most powerful
aspects of meditation but
you also said something else which which
i want to pick up on
which is the reason more people don't
meditate you said
you said something along the lines of i
know in meditation you're not supposed
to latch on to any thought right
yeah that's rubbish that's completely
not true
see there are different types of
meditation in fact there's so many
different types of meditation i
hate using the word meditation rather i
call it a transcendent practice
a transcendent practice is any practice
where you
you go out of the physical world and you
go within so
meditation breathing in and out box
breathing is a transcendent practice
but closing your eyes and just being
grateful for your life is a transcendent
practice closing your eyes and thinking
compassionately about someone you love
is a transcendent practice and
thinkitation is a transcendent practice
you're going within
and then there's modern meditation which
is about becoming better
at the world meditation is not about
becoming better at meditation it's about
becoming better
at functioning in the modern world and
so when you
understand that transcendent practices
are these beautiful things we can tap
into to get better
at life you see meditation in a
completely different way meditation
helps you bend reality there is a myth
out there in the world
that i call the hustle me it says that
it's about hard work that it's about
working harder than the competition
it's about busting your back for 100
hours a week
i call [ __ ] on that because i also
see people
who take who focus on themselves first
who have a steady meditation practice
who learn how to
tap into intuition and then how to
visualize their goals
and they work significantly less but get
far better results
you can hustle or you can surrender into
your inner space
and i'm a big fan of surrendering into
your inner space hustling
to me is an outdated broken approach
that leads to
overwork it leads to broken marriages it
leads to poor relationship with your
kids it leads to aging faster
don't hustle it's a myth also if you
want to have more confidence self-love
self-belief check out my 254 series
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to build a habit
so i've designed a special free
program to help you get it where i will
send you an unlisted video
to your email for the next 254 days to
shift
your self-belief forward the link to
sign up for free is in the description
below
you were up and dressed and ready to go
before your parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding
to expect the unexpected if you didn't
give a [ __ ] what anybody else thought
what's the thing you would love to be
doing with your life you should ask
yourself
first and foremost why do you create
content hack number four
divorce the mind body relation with
andrew huberman
throughout the day and throughout the
year we're confronted with different
things
right now we're confronted with a lot of
things 2020 is the year of being
confronted with stress
of various kinds the mind
plays an important role in interpreting
whether or not it's overwhelming
or tolerable so intense breathing like
tumor breathing or
ice baths or cold showers or intense
exercise like you know high intensity
interval training type stuff
teaches the mind to be comfortable in
these higher
stress states where in other words it
teaches people to be comfortable when
they have a lot of adrenaline in their
body
this is like is basically stress
inoculation but stress inoculation is
not about not getting stressed it's
actually about
divorcing the mind-body relationship a
bit so that you're
calm in the mind when your body is very
amplified yeah so if you've ever done
tumor-type breathing or you've done a
cold shower
the goal is to get the adrenaline
release and then calm your mind and then
calm your mind and stay in the ice now
like
i'm exhausted i'm freezing but more like
no i can handle this that's right
hack number five mind what you focus on
with jim quick
years ago my my little sister started
sending me emails and postcards and
pictures a photograph of a very specific
kind of dog
it was a pug dog you know those little
dogs exactly
yes exactly very smooshy faces they're
very compliant you could dress them up
as
ballerinas and they don't they don't
care and and she starts and i didn't
know why so my question was like why is
she sending me these pictures all the
time that became a quite a dominant
question of the day
and then i realized her birthday was
coming up so she's she's a smart
marketer right
planting those seeds and here's the
magic though
i started seeing pug dogs everywhere
everywhere i would go to the grocery
store i'd be checking out and i swear to
you a woman's carrying a pug dog at the
register
i would be running and jogging in my
neighborhood and somebody's walking
six pug dogs now my question for
everybody is
where where where did these pug dogs
magically appear all the sudden
in the world no they were always there
but they were not
i wasn't paying attention to them
because they weren't important because i
wasn't asking that question
once you ask a question you start to pay
attention to those things
and that focus determines how you feel
determines your behaviors
and primarily it's so interesting it's
kind of like social media
there's an algorithm to your mind like
there's an algorithm to facebook and
instagram
that what you engage with the most you
like and you share you comment you start
seeing
more of those kind of things right and
so just like your mind
what you start engaging with if you
start watching all this news about fear
and all the things that are going on you
start paying attention
and your mind just starts focusing
automatically becomes a
reaction or a reflex and you start to
attract more of the fear and anxiety or
worry that's in the world that's being
posted
very much so you start to subscribe to
whatever that is to receive more of it
exactly what you're thinking about so
just like on social media if you start
just liking all the cat stuff and
everything else they'll just start
feeding you cat stuff
and same thing with negativity and same
thing with opportunity also as well
hack number six do the opposite for 48
hours with tim ferriss
what if i did the opposite for 48 hours
it's a very recoverable experiment right
if it doesn't work then i can always go
back to what i was doing
doing the opposite met making my calls
between
let's just say 6 30
and 8 30 and then 5 30 to
7 7 30. and uh
it was just a hypothesis uh maybe i can
get a hold of the people i need to get a
hold of more effectively
when the gatekeepers aren't there right
and that's exactly what happened
and i started booking more meetings and
closing more deals than
than the majority of the guys in the
company and it was just from asking that
question what if i did the opposite for
48 hours and you can apply that to
many many things some of the others uh
would be
well this is one i asked in 2004. if i
had a gun against my head and could only
work two hours per week
what would i do i know it's impossible
what would i do
and that type of ludicrous question
was necessary to break my
thinking patterns and test stress test
my own assumptions of what was possible
and hack number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is free yourself with dr joe dispenza
if you're not being defined by a vision
of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future
as you see the same people and you go to
the same places and you do the exact
same thing at the exact same time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is
affecting or creating your personality
your environment is really controlling
how you think and feel unconsciously
because every person everything every
place every experience has a
neurological network in your brain
every experience that you have with
every person produces an emotion so
some people will use their boss to
reaffirm their addiction to judgment
they'll use their enemy to reaffirm
their addiction to hatred they'll use
their friends to reaffirm their
addiction to suffering so now
they need the outer world to feel
something
so to change then
is to be greater than your environment
to be greater than the conditions in
your world and the environment is that
seductive
so then why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's close our eyes
let's disconnect
from your outer environment so if you're
seeing less things there's less
stimulation going to your brain
if you're playing soft music or you have
ear plugs in
less sensory information coming to your
brain so you're disconnecting from your
environment
if you can sit your body down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here
i'm going to feed you when we're done
you can get up and check your emails you
can do all your texts but right now
you're going to sit there and obey me so
then
when you do that properly and you're not
eating anything or smelling anything or
tasting anything you're not up
experiencing and feeling anything
you would have to agree with me that
you're being defined by a thought
right so when the body wants to go back
to its emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy
you're siphoning your energy out of the
present moment into the past
and you become aware of that and you
settle your body back down in the
present moment because it's saying well
it's 8 o'clock you normally get upset
because you're in traffic around this
time
and here you are sitting and we're used
to feeling angered and you're off
schedule
oh it's 11 o'clock and usually check
your emails and judge everybody well
the body's looking for that that
predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is
craving those emotions and you settle it
back down into the present moment you're
telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will
is getting greater than the program and
if you keep doing this over and over
again over and over again over and over
again
just like training a stallion or a dog
it's just gonna say
i'm gonna sit and the moment that
happens
when the body is no longer the mind when
it finally surrenders
there's a liberation of energy we go
from particle to wave
from matter to energy and we free
ourselves from the chains
of those emotions that keep us in the in
the familiar past and
we've seen this thousands of times in
fact we can actually predict it now on a
brain scan
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
percent
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following through jump
to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps in 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below and
i'm going to celebrate alongside with
you
you have allowed too many negative
voices into your head and they're
preventing you from achieving your
dreams
maybe it's your friends your parents
your community the people around you
or worst of all maybe it's yourself
you cannot do great things with those
negative voices inside your head you
need to eject them
immediately and this video will show you
how
so i have a term for those negative
voices i call it the little man the
little man
is the either the voice inside your head
or the people around you telling you all
the reasons why
you're not going to win all the reasons
why this project this idea this stream
of yours
is not going to happen it's never going
to happen not a million years is that
going to happen
right we all have people in our life who
tell us that or also
us telling ourselves and the idea for
little man
came from the very first video that
popped on my channel there was a video
called believe that i loved and
it was when i just discovered my who my
one word which is believe i just found
out what it was and i wanted to make
kind of a tribute video to that concept
on my youtube channel
and i made this video that was six and a
half minutes long or so
and i showed it to somebody who was in
the entertainment industry
and i asked him to take a look at it and
he he just destroyed it he said
this video is way too long six and a
half minutes
uh nobody's gonna watch it uh i didn't
understand how the internet worked
all sorts of comments about how bad this
video was
and to be honest a younger version of
evan might have listened to him and
tried to cut it down
and and make it fit within the box that
he wanted to be inside
and for whatever reason i just had a
little more strength and confidence and
said you know what
maybe maybe he doesn't like it but i'm
just gonna i'm gonna do it anyway
i'm gonna post it anyway i like it it
inspired me and if it inspired me maybe
it was gonna inspire other people too
so we posted it and at the time my best
video had a hundred thousand views it
took
uh took a year to get that video to a
hundred thousand views this video went
live and in a month had a hundred
thousand views
in the first month had a hundred
thousand views and now sits around i
think two million views on the channel
and so quickly became my best video now
it's not my best video but
at the time it was the first video to
you know pop after a month like this is
crazy it's taking up
and i thought man what if i listen to
the little man
what if i listen to him i came up with a
little man because it's something that
he
uh often jokes about so he calls other
people the little man and said
okay well he's the little man what if i
listen to him
i would have never done that video i
would have never
never built the channel i would have
been in a totally different place a much
smaller place a much more negative place
a much more
self-defeating place because i was
trying to you know fit into his box and
so
you know i'm grateful that i had the
courage at the time at least to
trust my gut and go with it but it's
this constant battle that we face
is the voice inside our head telling us
that we're not good enough it's the
people around us telling us that we're
never going to make it
sometimes out of love and sometimes out
of insecurity and it's why i think
everybody has michael jordan level
talent has helped them like you could be
the greatest
it's why believe is the number one
problem in the world
lack of belief is the number one problem
in the everything else is solvable
believing that you could be the michael
jordan of something that you
you have the ability to be the greatest
in the world at something that belief
like really feeling that you could be
the greatest in the world of something
how would your life change how would
your actions change how would it change
what you do today right you're watching
this
espresso in the morning how does your
life today change
if you actually believe that you had
michael jordan level talent at something
that's what i'm trying to do and it
starts with you kicking out the
negativity in your head so what's the
three step process to eliminate
negativity from your life and start
building your dream
here we go step number one is pay
attention to your energy
so pay attention to the people that
you're around the media you're consuming
what are you doing on a daily basis and
pay attention carefully
to what gives you energy and what sucks
your energy
most things will suck your energy most
people will suck your energy
most media consumption will suck your
energy right hopefully not this video
hopefully this video we're pumping up
the energy but if it's sucking your
energy stop watching go to go do
something else
right so we start by doing an audit you
start by looking at all the people
around you
and what you're consuming and where
you're spending your time and then you
start scoring it you see like where am i
losing the most energy who are the
who are the people that when i leave a
meeting with them or i leave
hanging out with them i feel tired i
feel like i need to go nap i feel like i
need a shower
right and there's other people that when
you leave meeting with them you feel
amazing you feel more fired up you feel
ready to go you feel
you feel bold and courageous and
powerful and want to take on the world
right
we don't have enough of those people in
our lives most people so
make a list of who are the worst
offenders right just just
do that self-audit to go through who
you're hanging out with on any kind of
consistent basis
and who are the worst offenders in terms
of leaving you in a more negative spot
than when you came in
step number two is eliminate or restrict
access so
some people if they're really negative
and they make you feel worse about
yourself
stop hanging out with them right some
people you can just do that just because
you happen to be their friend
in kindergarten doesn't mean that you
should still be their friend right like
people grow a lot of us are in
friendships out of convenience just
because it's always been
but you've grown a lot in the past five
years or 10 years
just because you were friends with them
before doesn't mean that you still need
to be friends now
it doesn't mean you're disrespectful it
doesn't mean that you yell at them or
hate them or anything just
stop spending time with them right those
those negative people in your life
you've grown beyond them and now they're
sapping your energy that's preventing
you from getting to where you need to be
now what do you do when they're your
family this is a tougher spot
if it's your parents as an example
that's usually the classic
one some people do cut off their parents
that's an extreme step
if you're getting no love no
consideration no respect maybe that
maybe that's a bold step that you need
to make but otherwise you just cut off
access to certain topics
you know that when you talk about x when
you talk about your career or your
business
it always leads to a fight this is where
you
need to become the adult in the
relationship it's a really hard
leap for a lot of people to make right
your parents are used to being parents
and they're adults but they're acting
like kids
you need to step up and be the bigger
person now you need to be the adult in
this relationship
and cut off access to topics i'm not
talking about this because every time we
do we get into a fight
so let's talk about something else
whether that's the rest of the family
you know the the the new dog the weather
the sports team whatever like whatever
there's enough of a connection between
you and your parents that you can still
talk about without having to talk about
this thing that you know is gonna
be a bomb every time and you decide and
you lay down the law
like this does not happen we are not
talking about this you have to own the
relationship and take responsibility
you're an adult now they're not
parenting you anymore
right and most people don't have the
confidence to step into that role
but you need to if you want to have a
happy relationship with them
and also self-love for yourself so you
either eliminate the negative people
or you cut off access either with
frequency with time
or to certain topics that you're not
going to talk about with these people
anymore because it only leads to
negativity and stress
and then step number three is fill the
void with boldness now that you're not
spending time with
negative people and you're not consuming
negative content online and in books and
podcasts or anywhere else you fill it
with positivity with boldness
like not just happiness but boldness
what makes you feel bold
if it's these videos then hey i got
videos every day for you
if it's a 254 then open the 254 every
day if it's learning from joe rogan
he's got a podcast too go check it out
whoever it is
if it's books podcasts youtube channels
right whatever the thing is it makes you
feel
bold bold powerful confident alive that
makes you feel like you can do anything
inject that into your daily routine so
we're identifying the negativity in our
life
we're eliminating it or cutting enough
access to it and then in that void
in that chasm now we're filling it with
the things that make us feel bold do
that
do that today you're going to change
your life
[Music]
if you want to know how to condition
yourself for success check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there most people
uh when they have a thought they just
think that that's the truth
and i think one of my greatest
realizations in my own journey was
just because you have a thought doesn't
necessarily mean it's true